welcome back to gamma unfiltered hosted
by me josh smith and today we're joined
by the star of it's a sin it's neil
patrick harris
well i've seen the first episode of it's
to sin and it is one of the most
powerful
episodes of tv i've seen in a really
really long time
and your character's journey on it is so
heartbreaking
and for you when doing the research into
this character
and diving into that time what was some
of the things that shocked you
about what you learned well i didn't
have to do a ton of research made i was
born
in 73. so the 80s i was there
the hiv aids crisis in its
infancy especially in the uk was such a
surprise
it was so though there were so many
unknowns
and that and and so much not discussed
that doing too much research kind of
defeated the purpose right we now
thankfully live in a world where
the conversation is so different but in
this digital world that we're in right
now we have so many options and so many
examples and so many forums
for being able to share that back then
in the 80s
um being being gay was something that
you
were you had to think through sharing
and then um being sick was even more
verboten right
and so i think that was
that was the challenge for me i guess
individually was how to maintain a sense
of decorum and dignity
and life um given
very juxtaposing circumstances i think
as well it really does play to that
societal
it really shines a light on the societal
pressure that is placed on
gay people within gay communities live
up to certain expectations and that
kind of internal battle you have
yourself to like you know try to be a
man
what that means how have you seen in
your own life that societal pressure
change and shift and how is your
response to it shifted as well
i agree with you so much and it's one of
my favorite things about watching the
series
is that you watch at least i watched it
in with two different lenses
simultaneously i really wanted the
i really wanted to watch these kids
uh learn who they were and ex be
voracious and
and have sex with all kinds of people
and grow up and have
fun and yet i was also simultaneously
watching it
with a lot of caution and and and
trepidation
because i was i was concerned for them
and i think that duality
is is very cool but i don't know for me
in my mid-40s i'm sort of i'm sort of
the last
generation of lots of labels it feels
you know
there's a there's a there's so many
examples now
of gay actors
of gay politicians of gay everyone's
that the label itself becomes less
important
because it kind of the saturation point
has been reached
and in point of fact when i talk to kids
who are a younger generation
like in their early 20s really a lot of
the cast
of the of the show
they don't they don't really the labels
don't define them
like i don't know i it seemed like when
i was growing up if a boy
made out with another boy it meant that
he was gay
and he had to then process what that
would mean
and how like if he was he willing to
take that step and acknowledge that he's
gay g-a-y
and now it seems like the younger
generations like
if they feel like making out with
somebody anybody that they can
and it's hot and it doesn't mean that
much they don't they don't carry the
the emotional baggage of what a label
may
represent the labels kind of have
vanished we live in a
we live in a world where there's great
gender non-conformity where you
need to specify your own personal
pronouns
and other people need to respect that
and that's that's different
that's been a litmus change that i think
is for
is is is obviously for the better
yeah when you think back to that time
when you were discovering yourself and
understanding
yourself and labels and all that kind of
stuff that comes with it
what was that journey like for you it
was so unique man because i started
working as an actor before i started
puberty
and i started puberty really late so
so i was i was acting on a tv show
you know before i really had any kind of
yearnings really and so for me it was
it was a and i kept working happily i
didn't feel like if
if anyone knew about i didn't i didn't
ever feel
i never felt stifled in my profession i
didn't feel stifled in my personal life
because i lived in los angeles
at a time when there were lots of
labeling was lots of labeling going on
labeling from who you're who you're
sleeping with but labeling on what
are you a tv actor or are you a movie
actor or are you a theater right there
was like all kinds of
boxes and so for me it was more i did i
didn't think
once i started realizing i wanted to
hump dudes
then i was like how do i how do i how do
i accomplish that
when do you start to come to terms with
yourself
do you think man
i feel like i feel like we're constantly
in that
constantly in that conversation and i at
least for me
i'm i'm nearing 50
and i still wonder why i'm this way and
wonder why my isms are that and when am
i going to
have more realizations about this
it shifts right it then becomes i'm a
parent to 10 year olds a boy and a girl
and i'm
even last night late last night i'm up
like hands on my head
stressed about how i'm parenting and and
what my thoughts are on school for the
kids and scholastic learning and what
that means for them so i'm
i'm insecure about who i am even as an
adult do you think the idea of being
an actor and having to be a hollywood
leading man
has also played into that discovery and
trying to rebel against that in some
ways
it's hard to answer that question
because i don't know what your
definition of hollywood leading man is
right action hero could be different
from
tom hanks could be different from
you know hot guy on the on
riverdale you know it's a it's a again
it's not a singular
phrase i think the job of the actor is
to take each individual piece of
of of script information
the project the episode the scene
that'll die at the line
and and make it seem as realistic as
possible so
if if some of that is deciding that your
definition of this character is someone
who has a deeper voice
or someone who carries themselves in a
much more suave way than you normally
would
then that's that's making a choice based
on your own personal
differences as opposed to saying i'm
gonna act straight
uh because again that's so subjective
because
uh people's definitions of these things
um
are different it's about where the
validation lies isn't it because
that's here it's not going you're not
looking elsewhere for it then you
actually have a
stronger sense of self too don't you 100
and and interestingly in order to find
that
strength in self i think you have to
have lived a bit
and gone through gone through some
things in order to have those
realizations
it's hard to ask someone to just
think that way you have to have
have a you know a modicum of self-shame
and
and and embarrassing examples of trying
things that didn't work in order to
realize what did work
that's one of the parental lessons i've
learned and i'm learning still
is teaching our kids to fail to want to
fail to try things with the goal
of it being sloppy
because a first draft of anything um
demands improvement and one of the
things i loved about it's a sin as well
as
it's a very powerful portrayal of the
mental health aspects
of sexuality of identity and i think the
way they present mental health is so
powerful
but you what's your own journey been
like with mental health and what have
been some
turning points in learning to look after
yourself i've been blessed with a
family and an upbringing that's
relatively
idyllic to me parents that are
were only married to each other still
married to each other still alive
no abuse an older brother who i'm still
close with
we lived in a small town where we had
autonomy and were able to
make our own decisions about a lot of
things so my upbringing was
was pretty swell if anything my own
my own journey had as much to do with
who i
um want to snog and more about
what i wanted to do i was oddly thrust
into a position of
of actor
early and it was super fun and i loved
doing it
but i did have to process was this what
i want to do
is is this like how do i define
even that given that i'm was working on
a
television show at a like in high school
very strange
so that was its own journey but i've
done like lots i'm a i'm a therapy
guy i have weekly therapy sessions even
to this day
i did a forum this group therapy thing i
did
a tony robbins seminar in hawaii
where i walked on coals burning coals
what was that like it's hot
but i think it's very powerful to talk
about that kind of stuff because you
learn so much
about yourself from talking about
yourself and listening to others as well
what's maybe a message or lesson you've
taken away from
that therapy experience it seems it
seems like everyone has their
stuff yeah
and it's it's easy to get mired in
your own stuff so doing those kind of
things at least
on a very simple level it's nice to see
that other people have
other stuff i'm putting stuff in
quotation marks through all of this
that um is often much more intense than
what you have gone through
uh and so to put to be able to put it in
like a
in a more of a global perspective was
helpful
but also when when you're within your
own insecurities and your own stresses
it's hard to not
have everything relate to that
if you're worried about your weight and
then someone
and that's all you think about is that
you don't you're not comfortable with
your body
and then someone walks up to you and
compliments you and says oh you look you
look really nice today
sometimes you don't even hear that as a
compliment right you hear that as why do
i normally look terrible you know
and and you spin whatever's happening
around you into the narrative that
you've already created
so therapy is helpful in that way to try
and take things
as they are and and
things will change and we're often two
things simultaneously
it's okay to um
be hard on yourself and love yourself
it's okay to
not like someone and respect
them you don't have to choose the one we
are dualities of ourselves all the time
we're constantly wanting to do something
and then
choosing the opposite thing and it's not
that we could have done one or the other
they're both kind of happening
simultaneously one of the things about
it's the sin as well
is the community and friendship aspect
which i think is so powerful but i was
wondering if you could go back
and be a friend to yourself at a time in
your life
when would it have been and what would
you say
to that you i probably would have been
friends with myself when i was
probably
17 or 18 maybe 18
and i probably would have let younger me
know
that um things change radically and
often
and the circumstances that you're
currently in won't be the circumstances
that you will currently be in
in a year much less a decade
i mean throughout this conversation
we've kind of talked about this
underlying idea of finding pride in
yourself and being proud of yourself
when do you think you've been the most
proud
of yourself do you think the last
18 24 months i've been probably the most
proud of myself as a person
because when you're a father
there is so much change and
and unstable ground
uh as they grow and change so radically
so quickly
and it just creates self-reflection and
insecurity and yet unbear
unbearably exciting milestones
and the opportunity to witness
uh what hard work can accomplish
you